alors que le coroner virus frappe de
plein fouet le pays le gouvernement et
les médecins répète à longueur de
journée qu'il n'y a pas assez de tests
pour dépister tout le monde ces tests ne
seront réalisés que sur les sujets les
plus atteints et les plus fragiles
pour le reste de la population le
message est clair restez chez vous et
attendez que ça passe
sauf que voilà depuis plusieurs jours
nombreuses sont les célébrités ou
politiques qui annoncent sur les réseaux
sociaux avoir été testés pour le court
aux navires us c'est le cas par exemple
de christian estrosi qui a même été
traité en priorité avec la chloroquine
mais aussi les ministres poirson et
franck riester ou encore dix huit autres
députés qui ont tous été diagnostiquée
alors qu'il n'affichait que des
symptômes légers il ya quelques jours
c'est le jeune chanteur lenny kim
candidats de danse avec les stars qui a
annoncé lui aussi avoir été testées
positives comme blaise matuidi alexia
laroche joubert kevin durant le prince
albert ii de monaco tom hanks ou même
harvey weinstein il ya quelques jours
face à une montée de fièvre thomas
vergara le mari de nabila s'était rendu
à l'hôpital pour se faire tester et les
résultats étaient négatifs mais alors
pour répète à longueur de journée qu'il
n'est pas possible de se faire tester
beaucoup se demandent pourquoi les
personnalités ont-elles visiblement le
droit à un traitement de faveur
alors dépistage du coronavirus les stars
sont-elles privilégiées alors il ya
beaucoup de gens voilà qui explique
qu'ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi il ya
tant de personnalités qui ont
coronavirus et qu'ils nient ce pourquoi
elles sont fait dépister et pas nous
quels sont vos pensées jean paul hamon
le problème c'est pas de savoir qui se
fait dépister ou pas le problème est de
savoir dans quel pays du quart monde on
est où on n'est pas foutu de dépister de
dépister tous les genres tous les gens
suspects c'est ça le vrai souci là moi
j'ai un ami qui travaille pas très loin
du luxembourg il envoie ses il envoie
ses patients se faire tester au
luxembourg ils le prennent dans leur ils
ont les résultats dans la journée
on se demande pourquoi on peut faire des
tests au luxembourg pourquoi les
allemands font 168 est par jour et
pourquoi nous on est en train de mégoter
sur les tests a déjà avec les masques ça
commence à bien faire
mais être incapable de fournir
suffisamment test pour tester toutes les
personnes qui en ont besoin vraiment ça
vraiment ça commence à énerver
ça va empêcher de dormir cette affaire
encore tiens jean paul hamon juste la
question que tout le monde nous pose là
sur twitter c'est pourquoi au luxembourg
en allemagne il des pistes au monde et
en france on n'y arrive pas à c'est quoi
le problème
mais parce qu'on est un pays de
branquignols on est endetté en
administration qui est pléthorique
on a on a six étages des agences au
ministère ils ont passé des six étages
il faut qu'ils aient des années que
c'est un peu partout autour de du
ministère et pendant ce temps là on
n'est pas foutu fabriquer des tests en
quantité suffisante
on est on est des pieds nickelés voilà
la vérité c'est ça la vérité donc c'est
quoi c'est un problème d'administration
n'est trop lent il ya trop de voilà il
ya trop de couches pour prendre des
décisions mais absolument là
actuellement les laboratoires ont
commencé à réagir les laboratoires
privés ont commencé à réagir on commence
à tester les gens directement dans leur
voiture en drive il sait terrasse sur
prescription médicale naturellement mais
combien de temps ça va durer combien de
temps on va voir de test on n'en sait
strictement rien alors on va revenir
vers vous dans un instant à andré
bercoff aussi qu'ils étaient avec nous
m'ont soir andré bonsoir syrie merci
d'être avec nous et andré merci d'être
avec nous andré et puis c'est bien c'est
diakhaté
bah oui c'est vrai alors andré les stars
est ce qu'elles sont privilégiés est ce
que vous comprenez qu'elle prenne stars
qu'ils se fassent dépister ou est-ce que
vous et comme vous êtes comme le docteur
amour qui dit franchement des des
branquignols traçons c'est pas une
question de star ou pas de star il
fallait que tout le monde soit dépistée
et on fait n'importe quoi
bari 10e rang alors soyons clairs il si
c'est plus facile
moi je vous dis ça mais c'est plus
facile pour une star donc quelqu'un qui
connaît des jambes se perdent dépister
ou pour quelqu'un qui veut les personnes
ces questions de réseau ou passe raconte
ses histoires ses célèbres la nature
humaine turne gens ici connaissent
quelqu'un plus rapidement et plus
proches quelqu'un d'autre mais il y aura
plus de facilité à se faire à se faire
effectivement examinée et se faire
dépister
mais c'est vrai qu'on pose la question
est moins frappée c'est pas tellement le
france libre en tilleul c'est qu'en
corée en corée du sud
il fait actuellement van huffel par jour
la corée du sud a plus que nous ces 110
kg voilà et en israël même chose en je
prends pas de singapour dont on conduit
compagnie certes ils ont eu des masques
et des tests à profusion pourquoi nous
on les a pas ça remonte à des années
c'est pas c'est pas à la il ya deux ans
ça remonte à des années des années c'est
qu'on se dit que ça va c'était il ya
deux ans cyril un playboy a même pas de
moi relisez m'attendais bien sûr oui ça
va pas mais nous le système social
français
nous on sait les italiens c'est des
rigolos ils savent pas faire mons et ben
ouais ça ne s'est pas non plus alors
jean jean paul hamon juste octobre à mon
avis c'est un manque d'organisation
dr amos et de l'organisation
à mon avis à mon avis et les deux parce
que c'est quand même totalement
incroyable que si on compare avec des
pays voisins qui sont capables de faire
des tests rapidement là on voit bien que
maintenant les laboratoires d'analysés
privés sont capables de réagir et on les
teste qu'il faut eux visiblement ils ont
le matériel qu'il faut puisque on a
commencé à faire des tests à grande
échelle mais jusqu'à il ya encore une
semaine c'était une vraie galère pour
pouvoir faire un test en ville donc
incontestable qu'il ya tic demande
tendant ce qui a fait tiquer en fait
docteur annoncé le gars qui fait le plus
parler c'est celui d'emmanuel wargon à
la secrétaire d'état la transition
écologique et solidaire qui a annoncé
dimanche être positive aux copies des
nobles et ce qui a fait tiquer beaucoup
de monde c'est ce qu' elle dit en
annonçant lundi j'étais d'être
moustiques et ce jour positive aux
communes 19 je n'ai que des symptômes
bénins à ce stade
j'applique la règle je reste chez moi
pour me reposer et protéger les autres
gars plein de gens qui ont dit pourquoi
elle s'est fait dépister plus qu'à lac
des cygnes bénin mais attendait parce
que tout simplement parce qu'elle fait
partie des familles à risque elle et
elle est mariée avec un urgentiste qui
qui lui
quand côtoient côtoie tous les jours des
gens qui sont qui sont positifs et je
pense que vraiment s'il y avait une
personne qu'on doit pas critiquer parce
qu'elle s'est fait tester c'est
emmanuelle wargon qui lie aux côtés de
quelqu'un qui qui prend des risques tous
les jours au contact des gens qui sont
encore dix de plus
donc là dessus c'est donc cette fausse
polémique c'est une mauvaise c'est une
mauvaise prochaine fausse polémique
voilà d'accord alors il y en a qui a n'a
pas pu s'empêcher de réagir sur le sujet
c'est michel cymes qui était encore et
ce soir c'est s'asseoir et un michel
cymes il était l'invité le ccaf il a
donc voulu critiquer le fait que
certaines personnalités notamment des
politiques auraient bénéficié de passe
droit pour être testés regarde souvient
le soir de municipales avec l'histoire
jacob qui avait dit qu'il était infecté
il ya eu michel barnier qui a fait une
vidéo où il allait parfaitement bien il
était en pleine forme et il nous disait
je voudrais vous annoncer que je suis
positif voire déjà l'intérêt quand même
est quand même assez mineures mais c'est
surtout que ça voulait dire qu'il avait
passé le test alors qu'il était en
pleine forme et ils sont en train de
nous casser tout ce qu'on essaye de
faire passer comme message de aux
français les messages de rigueur des
messages qu'on aura des tests mais que
tout le monde l'est parce c'est pas
grave mais là aujourd'hui on les a pas
et tous les gens célèbres qui vous
disent j'ai passé le test fut positif
nous cassent complètement les messages
qu'on essaye de faire passer
tranquillement aux français pour les
faire patients qu'est ce que vous dites
à saint andré bercoff ouais mais ça
c'est alors c'est un monument
d'hypocrisie comme j'ai jamais vu ça
lire ah là là en fait il faudrait pas
que ces célébrités comme la mèche
alors que tu effectivement nous rendons
s'est passé aux français après c'est pas
ça qui va c'est que on aime ça veut dire
on est en guerre on est en guerre on est
en guerre on est en guerre comme en 40
on ait la ligne maginot et en font
tourner donc ce sont les munitions ou
sur les clips sont les gènes sont les
masques il ya les médecins jean paul
hamon l'a dit plusieurs fois avec
beaucoup d'autres l'ont dit et sont fait
qu'est ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça j'ai pas le
progrès là il nous cache le truc avec
les des sages de rigueur
on se fout des messages de rigueur ce
qu'on veut savoir
qui si on ne prend pas ce truc c'est
avec l arbre comment il dise les choses
comme elles sont et arrêtez de raconter
l'histoire il ya un mois les masques ça
servait à rien aujourd'hui il faut des
masques vraiment ça y'a pas par semaine
il y avait bien dit pas grand chose
cette espèce de discours incohérent
permanence cette navigation à vue c'est
pas possible dit les choses d'état fort
de dire les choses
problème jean paul hamon y aurait
convaincu aujourd'hui en france qu on
parle de deux cent dix mille cas
aujourd'hui
oui mais ça ça veut strictement rien
dire ça veut strictement rien dire à
partir du moment où on n'a pas testé
tout le monde ça veut strictement ça
représente rien les chiffres qui
comptent actuellement ce sont les morts
et les gens qui sont raidies mation ça
ce sont des chiffres qui comptent et
qu'il faut particulièrement surveillé
parce que là on a plus de 2400 aux 2500
personnes en réanimation actuellement et
ça ce sont des chiffres ce sont des
chiffres qui comptent et qu'il faut
surveiller